If you've got a Bible with you,
do please turn with me to Ephesians chapter one,
or it's also there in your worship guide.
If you need that, there on the back.
Ephesians chapter one.
Last week we looked at this same passage
that we're looking at this morning,
and we focused on the spiritual blessings
that are ours in Christ.
We looked at adoption, election, redemption,
our inheritance.
But scripture's like a multifaceted diamond, right?
You can take the same passage
and turn it in a different direction
and see God's glory refracted in a different way.
So what I want us to do is look at the same passage
we looked at last week, but from a different angle.
And so last week we looked at the blessings,
and this week I really want us to see the God
who blesses us from this passage.
Now so let's read Ephesians chapter one,
verses three to 14 together.
It says, blessed be the God and father
of our Lord Jesus Christ,
who has blessed us in Christ
with every spiritual blessing in the heavenly places,
even as he chose us in him
before the foundation of the world,
that we should be holy and blameless before him.
In love he predestined us for adoption to himself
as sons through Jesus Christ,
according to the purpose of his will,
to the praise of his glorious grace,
with which he has blessed us in the beloved.
In him we have redemption through his blood,
the forgiveness of our trespasses,
according to the riches of his grace,
which he lavished upon us in all wisdom and insight,
making known to us the mystery of his will,
according to his purpose, which he set forth in Christ
as a plan for the fullness of time
to unite all things in him,
things in heaven and things on earth.
In him we have obtained an inheritance,
having been predestined according to the purpose of him
who works all things according to the counsel of his will,
so that we who were the first to hope in Christ
might be to the praise of his glory.
In him you also, when you heard the word of truth,
the gospel of your salvation and believed in him
were sealed with the promised Holy Spirit,
who was the guarantee of our inheritance
until we acquire possession of it
to the praise of his glory.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
The grass withers and the flowers fade,
but your word, oh Lord, stands forever.
So Father, as we open your word together,
I pray that you would plant it deeply in our hearts
and that you would cause it to bear fruit for your glory
in Jesus' name, amen.
Just as we get started, I'm gonna ask you a dangerous question.
What is the worst sermon you've ever heard?
And please don't say last week.
I've heard some pretty bad ones in my life.
I remember one was focused,
the whole thing was about UFOs, I kid you not.
Another one was a list of signs that you are only
pretending to be King James only.
In other words, that you only use
the King James version of the Bible.
And it was that, you say you only use that version,
but here's seven reasons why I know you're lying,
that you really would read other versions of the Bible.
A real sermon.
But perhaps the most recent sermon I've heard
that would maybe be on the list was at a dinner
that I went to and there was a speaker afterwards.
And they got up and they began their talk with a skit.
And so they actually went out into the crowd
and they passed out the script for the skit
and the microphone got passed around.
And the skit was a way of explaining the gospel.
And the skit started off with somebody
who was God the Father.
And God the Father was really, really angry.
He was furious at all of humanity, like all of us.
He's mad.
And he is going to punish us.
But then, person number two steps in, God the Son.
And he's saying, Dad, please no, don't punish them.
I love them.
And I want to go and give myself and die in their place.
And the Father was not having it.
And they argued back and forth about this in this play.
And then it got so bad that they needed a mediator
to step in.
And you guessed it sadly, in walks the Holy Spirit
who then functioned as a mediator
between God the Father and God the Son
so that they could come to an agreement
that yes, he would allow the Son to come
and die for us.
It was cringe worthy to say the least.
The angry Father, the benevolent Son
and the peacemaking Spirit.
But at least within the explanation maybe,
there's pointing us to the fact that yes,
God is a Trinity, Father, Son and Holy Spirit
in this one God.
But that isn't enough to just say
God is Father, Son and Spirit.
You know, at best maybe it tells us
that we should praise Jesus for having died for us.
But it leaves us with a questionable view of the Father.
And not really knowing who the Holy Spirit is at all.
But our text this morning,
from the angle we're gonna see it from,
shows us all three of the persons of the Trinity
working together in perfect harmony to save us.
This is the God that we praise.
Verse three, blessed be the God and Father
of our Lord Jesus Christ who has blessed us
with every spiritual blessing in Christ Jesus.
So right from the beginning of this long sentence
where Paul is praising God, you see Father, Son and Spirit,
we're blessed by the Father.
He's the eternal loving Father of Jesus Christ, his Son.
You see that there?
We are blessed in Christ.
So we're blessed in the Son.
And we're blessed with every spiritual blessing.
And of course, as we saw last week,
that tells us about the nature of these blessings.
But it also alludes to the fact
that they are conveyed to us by the Holy Spirit.
You see that develop as the chapter goes on.
But here's the point, the persons of the Trinity
do not work at odds with one another in our redemption.
They work together in perfect harmony
so we can sing as we do the doxology.
Praise Father, Son and Holy Ghost.
And this symphony of redemption occurs
in three movements that we see here.
And the three movements are the fact
that it was planned by the Father
and then secondly that it was accomplished by the Son.
And then thirdly and lastly,
we see that it was applied by the Spirit.
Now we're gonna work through all three of those
this morning, but just to forewarn you,
we're gonna give more time to the first two
and touch on the last one
and then spend more time next week looking at that.
So if we get two thirds of the way through
and you're like, we've got another one,
just know there's not gonna be much time there at the end.
So first of all, our redemption is planned by the Father.
These blessings that we've received in Christ
have been given to us because of the Father's plan.
So Paul repetitively in this section here
draws our attention to God's sovereignty.
He talks about God's will in verses five, nine and 11.
He talks about God's purpose or his good pleasure
in verses five and nine.
In verse 10, he talks about God's plan.
In verse 11, he talks about God's counsel.
Last week we looked at the verbs that are there as well.
So he talks about God choosing and predestining.
But I wanna draw our attention particularly
to verses nine and 10.
So last week I mentioned this 202 word sentence.
You know, Paul is just gushing with praise.
A lot is happening, but he gets to the main point
of what he's saying in verses nine and 10.
Okay, these verses really summarize what he's saying here
that's kind of pinnacle, but also they summarize
the message of the entire book of Ephesians.
So if you're wondering what this whole series is about,
it's summarized in verses nine and 10.
And there we see that God is making known to us
the mystery of his will according to his purpose,
which he set forth in Christ as a plan
for the fullness of time to unite all things in him,
things in heaven and things on earth.
Do you see the plan of the father there?
A few years ago I traveled up to Scotland
to visit some friends of mine.
There's a couple called Mark and Jill
and there's many fascinating things
about this wonderful couple.
One of the sort of fascinating facts about them
is Jill is an author, she's a published author,
she's a great writer.
And so one of the things that I asked them
while I was up there with them,
I said, Jill, what is your creative process?
Like what does that look like?
So when you're writing a book,
do you kind of start on the journey
and like you don't know where it's gonna go
and you kind of develop it over time?
Or do you sort of plan it all out in advance?
And by the look on her face,
you could tell that I asked the right question.
Like she was ready, she was waiting on somebody
to finally ask.
And she said, hold on just a second.
And she went from the living room
back into like a back bedroom
and she came back out with the biggest piece of paper
I've ever seen in my life.
And it was all folded up.
And she took this piece of paper
and then she then unfolded this paper.
And as she unfolded the paper, you could see on it,
there was all the characters listed out of her next book.
You could see the title of her next book there.
You could see the kind of the plot
and the chapters kind of all mapped out
and then how it was gonna resolve at the end
all there on this piece of paper
that she unfolded before me.
It was all mapped out.
And so what we see here,
we have this kind of mystery
that was there in redemption,
but now it is unfolded before us.
We have God's unfolding plan of redemption.
He's not kind of making it up as he goes
or kind of responding to things as it plays out.
Our lives exist as part of a story
that has been mapped out by God
and is playing out in time.
In Ephesians one, the author here unfolds it before our eyes
and shows it planned from beginning to end.
So a few things about the plan.
One is we see the origin of the plan here.
So verse nine, it was planned according to God's purpose.
So the plan of redemption unfolding before us
was determined by God's purpose
or according to his good pleasure.
And that includes not just the plan in general
but also our place in that plan.
So how does God come up with this plan?
Well, verse 11 tells us,
according to the counsel of his will.
So what does that mean?
Well, it means that God's redemption plan
wasn't determined based on any outside influence
beyond himself.
It is his desires being fulfilled
according to his all-wise and foreordained plan.
So it was his desire that is being fulfilled in redemption.
So you got the origin of the plan from God
but also you see the scope of the plan here
because God is sovereign not over a lot of things
or most things but over everything.
And so everything is included in his redemption plan.
His plan includes all things in heaven and on earth
and in verse 10 he works.
How many things according to the counsel of his will?
Verse 11, all things.
Nothing is outside of the scope of his sovereignty.
It includes all things and also all time.
We might think of time as being something that is forever
but that's not what is presented to us in scripture.
God's purposes were determined before time existed
and they are being fulfilled in time
but there is coming a day when time will be fulfilled.
In other words, history as we know it
will come to a final conclusion,
a conclusion, a resolution that was determined by God.
So the story is planned out from start to finish.
So what's the goal of this plan?
We might ask.
What's God aiming at here?
You know, Richard Dawkins once described the universe
as being a place of no design, no purpose, no evil, no good,
nothing but blind, pitiless indifference.
Encouraging, right?
But that's not what we see here.
Here we see that God has designed the universe
with a purpose in mind.
What is the purpose?
The goal is the praise of his glory.
You see that repeated three times in the passage.
Verse six, verse 12, verse 14,
everything exists not only by him but also for him.
So another couple of texts to throw in here too.
Romans chapter 11 verse 36 ties these two together.
It says for from him and through him
and to him are all things to him be glory forever.
Revelation chapter four verse 11,
God is being praised.
And it says worthy are you, our Lord and God
to receive glory and honor and power for you created all things.
And by your will they were existed and were created.
So everything exists for God's glory.
In the making of the 16th century,
you had this guy called Copernicus.
Remember what he proposed?
He proposed this crazy idea
that the earth revolved around the sun.
And it wasn't that it wasn't the other way around
because people believe that everything revolved
around the earth.
It was a really controversial idea at the time
that the earth revolved around the sun.
It was hard for people to believe
but nevertheless it was true.
It may be a more controversial thing
to say that the glory of God
is the center of all existence but it is truth.
You know and although we wouldn't say this out loud maybe
we tend to think and live as though everything
revolves around us sometimes.
You know we want things to be according to the counsel
of our will.
We have our desires and we live to fulfill those desires.
We may conceptualize of life
as ourselves as being at the center.
Like I'm at the center and around me are kind of
my desires, my plans, my career, my money,
my friends, my family, and maybe even my faith.
And God is out there on the periphery.
And if all that feels overwhelming or out of sorts
it's because we weren't designed in that way.
We're not here to do our will but to do God's will.
We're not here to make much of ourselves.
We're here to make much of him.
He is not part of our story.
We are part of his.
We were created for a purpose
and that purpose is the praise of his glory.
And if that doesn't feel like good news
notice how God wants to be glorified in us.
His plan is to be glorified by pouring out his grace
on our lives.
So here in Ephesians one,
God isn't being glorified just in a general sense.
He's being glorified for his grace.
So verse six speaks of the praise of his glorious grace.
Verse seven speaks of the riches of his grace.
And in verse 14 he wraps things up
by talking about God being glorified
in giving us an inheritance.
So yes, God created everything
with the goal of his glory in mind
but there's a particular glory that he wanted to receive.
And that was to be glorified for the grace
that he has shown to the people he has redeemed.
So God's unflinching commitment to his glory
brings about our everlasting good.
He displays his glory in this way
by setting his love upon us,
by adopting us into his family,
by redeeming us from slavery to sin
and by bringing us into the eternal inheritance
he has prepared for us.
So we were made for something infinitely greater
than relying on ourselves to fulfill our will.
We were made to live by God's grace for his glory.
This is the Father's plan.
But it doesn't just make plans, he fulfills them.
He fulfills all of them.
Isaiah chapter 46 verses nine and 10,
God says this, he says,
I am God and there is no other.
I am God and there is no one like me
declaring the end from the beginning.
And from ancient times things not yet done
saying my counsel shall stand
and I will accomplish all of my purpose.
So God accomplishes all that he plans.
So how was his redemption plan accomplished?
Let's move this into the second thing.
It is accomplished by the Son.
So the Father's redemptive plan is accomplished
through the redemptive work of the Son.
It's accomplished by Jesus when he came into this world.
His plan in verse nine, there at the end of the verse
is set forth in Christ.
And that word set forth means to lay before.
You might think of like, I don't know,
an architect laying out a blueprint.
He sets it before him.
So he set out this redemptive plan
that he is going to accomplish in Christ.
It is before him.
That's what God was looking at in eternity.
And then when he pours out his grace on our lives
he pours it out on us in Christ.
He pours it out on those who are united to Christ.
So we've seen it right the way through.
Chosen, yes, but chosen in him.
We are adopted, yes, but we are adopted
through Jesus Christ.
We are redeemed, set free from sin,
how through his blood he paid the price for our sin.
We have been given an eternal inheritance.
Where?
Verse 11, in him.
So it's in Christ that all the blessings
of God are received.
One of my favorite places to go as a kid
was Six Flags over Georgia.
You haven't been there?
And I remember going to,
we'd go in the summertime and it'd be really, really hot
and you'd just be wanting to cool down somehow,
but I remember finding the perfect place to cool down.
And there was a ride aptly called Splashwater Falls.
I think it's been discontinued.
The Splashwater Falls, it takes you up in this boat
all the way to the top of this kind of waterfall
and it drops you down and as it gets down to the bottom,
there's just this huge splash that's there.
And the best place to get the refreshment of that splash
was not on the boat.
It was on the bridge, yes.
There was a little bridge that went across
and you just knew that the place to get that
was on that bridge and it was amazing.
You could think of, I don't know,
this passage is that kind of tidal wave of blessing.
Like it's really coming on thick here.
All these blessings that we have been given
and there's a place that we can know that we are loved by God,
that we are His children, that we're set free from our sins,
that we have an eternal hope.
Where is that place where we can receive
all of these things where this tidal wave of blessing
comes over us?
It is in Christ.
It's through faith in Him, if you will,
that we step on to that bridge.
He is the bridge in that sense.
So we receive those blessings, verse 13,
when we believe in Christ.
That's how we can know we are in Him,
if our faith is in Him.
I wanna draw your attention to a couple of things
this week in verses nine and 10,
that sort of draws into the bigger picture
of what Christ accomplished when He came into the world.
We focused on those individual blessings last week,
but remember, these two verses encapsulate
what the whole book is about.
So, what is the plan that God sets forth in Christ
for the fullness of time?
Here it is.
To unite all things in Him in heaven and on earth.
So what's the plan that He accomplished?
The plan to unite all things in Him.
What does that mean?
What's He talking about here?
Well, the word unite means to sum up
or to draw together into one.
If it's helpful, maybe you can think of,
I don't know, like the Amazon River.
So you got 1,100 tributaries
that all make up this one river.
They're all flowing into this singular river
and all them being brought to the same end.
So all of history and all of creation
is moving towards the goal for which it was created
and what draws it all together
and brings it to that end?
It's Christ and what He accomplished
through His life and death and resurrection and ascension.
So God's plan of redemption doesn't just include us.
It includes all of creation, the whole spectrum of creation.
So to give you another verse, Romans chapter eight
and verse 21 says, creation itself will be set free
from its bondage to corruption
and obtain the freedom of the glory
of the children of God.
Did Jesus come to set us free?
Absolutely, but not only us, not just redeem us
but the whole spectrum of creation.
So when we look at the world around us,
we might look and see, this is a world of suffering
and we might start to think, well, maybe this is a universe
of blind, pitiless indifference,
but there is coming a day when everything will be made right,
when all things will be made new,
when everything will be brought into alignment
with God's good purposes.
And on that day, all of creation
will reflect his goodness and his beauty.
So Jesus' reign and his redemptive work
will be fully realized at the end of time.
When he comes again, there will be a new creation
and we will there dwell with him forever.
And there everything will be united,
drawn together under his reign.
But there is a place where his reign
and the unity that that brings can be seen now
and that is in the unity of the church.
Now the church is to be a microcosm
for what he has planned for the whole of creation.
So Paul goes on to talk about those
who are heading towards that inheritance,
like that perfect new creation that we will step into
where all the whole spectrum of creation
is united in Christ.
Who's heading for that inheritance?
Well, there are two groups of people that he mentions
and then he mentions about how God has united them together
and you see that throughout the rest of Ephesians.
But who are these two groups of people?
One, those who were the first to hope in Christ,
in verse 12, he includes himself in that number.
And he talks about others who hear and believe
the gospel.
So what's going on here when he's saying
the people moving towards that perfect end
are those who were the first to hope in Christ
and everyone who believes the gospel.
Who were the first to hope in Christ?
They were Jews who had put their faith in God
and put their trust in Jesus as their Messiah and King.
And it's interesting when you read this passage
in light of the Old Testament scriptures,
you see that this resonates with what God
has been saying all along.
God promised to bless Abraham, Genesis 12,
and his descendants after him.
They were a chosen people, his children,
his redeemed you that brought out of Egypt.
The heirs of his promises.
Those who were the first to put their hope in Christ
received these ultimately in him.
But the same language is applied
to everyone who puts their faith in Christ
regardless of their ethnicity.
And this has been God's plan all along.
It was a mystery that was hidden
and now this mystery is made known.
So God's plan has always been for there to be
one people together, a united people
that he pours out his blessings upon.
It's this multi-ethnic people called the church.
And it was Christ's finished work
that brings about this united new humanity.
So you see this in Revelation 5.9.
Christ is praised, worthy are you it says,
for you were slain and by your blood
you ransomed people for God from every tribe
and language and people and nation.
So how can we know that we are included
in this chosen people of God, in this family of God,
in the inheritors of God's promise?
Once again, verse 13, by believing in Jesus,
are you trusting in Christ as your King?
And then we need to ask ourselves the questions,
well, how do we glorify God as his church
by living together in unity under his reign today?
That's what we'll be doing forever.
We'll be praising God together in perfect unity one day.
God calls us to do that now together,
to live under his reign, to learn to love one another
as we have been loved by Christ
and to live together for the glory of his name.
So redemption is planned by the Father
accomplished by the Son.
And lastly, briefly, applied by the Spirit.
So what's going on now?
So we look back yet, that's what Jesus accomplished
when he died, rose again and ascended,
but what's God doing today?
This redemption plan is still rolling out,
it is still being realized,
and it's being realized by the work of the Spirit.
Last week we saw that the Holy Spirit
is given to everyone who believes in Christ.
He's given as a seal, verse 13,
showing that we belong to him.
He's given as a guarantee, a first installment
or a foretaste of that day that's coming
when we dwell with God forever.
So this is how secure our redemption is.
God planned it and his plans never fail.
The Son accomplished it, he paid the price in full
and he's going to get exactly what he paid for.
And now he gives us his Holy Spirit
to ensure that we enter into all that he has promised.
Imagine surprising a family member or a friend of yours
with just the perfect presence.
Like say their favorite band is Coldplay.
I don't know what your favorite band is,
but their favorite band is Coldplay
and they've always wanted to go to Paris
and they've never been able to go to Paris
and you see that Coldplay
is going to be playing in Paris
and you've planned this trip.
Like you quietly scheme and you buy the tickets,
you buy the plane tickets, you've got the hotel,
it's all lined up and ready to go.
And then it comes time for the trip to take place
and you go and knock on your friend's door
early in the morning, you ring the doorbell
and their eyes open, they wake up,
they don't know what is going on
and you come and give them this huge surprise.
And then you guys get in the car together
and you drive them to the airport,
you get on the flight with them
and you take them exactly to this amazing trip
that you have planned for them.
We have something so much better here.
The Holy Spirit is what?
God's presence with us, bringing us into all the good
that God has planned for us.
So we are asleep.
In fact, not to get ahead of ourselves,
we're dead and our trespasses and sins.
But the Spirit wakes us up.
It gives us eyes to see the glory of Jesus.
And then the Holy Spirit begins to show us
all the blessings that are ours in Jesus.
And then that same Spirit empowers us
and leads us forward into the good works
that God has planned for us.
And eventually into the eternity
that awaits us with God forever.
So Romans 8, 11 says,
it is the Spirit of Him who raised Jesus from the dead,
who dwells in you.
He who raised Jesus from the dead
will also give life to your mortal bodies
through His Spirit who dwells within you.
More about the Spirit next week.
So we've seen this morning
that the glory of the triune God
is revealed in the gospel.
So what difference should that make to our lives?
Just two things.
One, it shows us the purpose of our lives.
As we said a moment ago,
we were made to live by God's grace
and for God's glory.
Are we pursuing that?
Are we pursuing something else?
Are we trying to live by our own strengths,
chasing after our own plans, our own dreams?
Are we, let's pray that we can learn to live
under the reign of Jesus by the help of His Spirit.
So it shows us the purpose of life,
but also let's rejoice in the fact that it gives us hope.
If we're in Christ, we can move forward with confidence
knowing that God is working out His plans
even when we mess up.
You know, what's the worst thing that's ever happened?
I'd say the murder of the Son of God, wouldn't you?
But what is the greatest thing that has ever happened?
The death of Jesus.
So God is able to take the worst tragedy
and through that bring about the greatest triumph.
He fulfills all His plans.
No, our plans don't always work out as we hope.
Sometimes that's due to circumstances outside of our control,
but sometimes that is due to our own stupidity,
maybe our own foolish decisions,
maybe even our own sin.
But even when that happens,
we can look to Christ.
We can look to Christ knowing that
God's plans will not fail.
If we are included in Him, we can say,
as Alex mentioned earlier in Romans 8, 28,
we can say with confidence,
all things work together for the good of those
who love God, for those who are the called
according to His purpose.
We are secure in Christ.
Let's pray.
Lord, thank you so much for your great plan
of redemption.
And so Lord, by your spirit,
I pray that you would open our eyes
to see more of what you have done for us in Christ,
what He has accomplished,
and the security of the hope that we have in Him.
Help us to live by your grace and for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen.